desde 1999 en chile- la presidencia
siempre se la lleva el ganador de la
primera vuelta pero este año es
diferente aunque el ultraderechista josé
antonio kast a venció en la primera
ronda lo hizo solo por unos dos puntos
de diferencia al respecto de gabriel
boric de izquierda y se cree que este
último podría aventajar el próximo
domingo porque
a ver hola buenas tardes buenas noches
nosotros tenemos el próximo domingo el
balotaje
esto está con 50% más uno lo de hoy el
voto para ser presidente de chile y los
dos quedaron muy lejos del 50 por ciento
en la primera vuelta por lo tanto hay
bastante incertidumbre acá existe un
blackout o una veda encuestas por lo
tanto ya no tenemos hace más de 10 15
días no tenemos sondeos oficiales son
todos oficiosos los que están dando
vueltas y en general la tendencia sigue
siendo favorable a la centroizquierda de
gabriel boric levemente por sobre
el representar de la extrema derecha y
después antonio kast mañana es un día
muy importante porque es el último
debate y el último debate que lo ve
mucha gente términos de la televisión
acá según en todo las redes y todas las
canales de televisión para transmitir
los multar ya mente y se espera que de
ahí salga de un auto forma en la
decisión de él o indeciso que queda hay
que recordar que en chile el voto
y por lo tanto no sabemos ni cuánta
gente a participar ni cuál va a ser en
general con un poquito más de certeza
cómo está en su favor y la
gobernabilidad de la presidencial se
supone que gabriel boliche para
levemente por sobre los centros rurales
bueno hacia allá iba mi siguiente
pregunta a ver cómo me la puede
responder tras la votar la constituyente
de las elecciones regionales y después
lo primero vuelta presidencial usted
cree que los chilenos están saturados ya
lo hemos dicho sólo 47 por ciento votó
en la presidenciales de un país con
altas tasas de abstencionismo como cree
usted pese a que es difícil predecir lo
que será la participación de este 19 de
diciembre en esta elección que además es
trascendental en este momento de la
historia del país si una de las
características más esenciales del
sistema chileno de lo último 89 años que
cuando se voluntarista el voto ante era
sin otro régimen es que los públicos o
los electores que votan en cada elección
son víctimas es decir hay una base que
se mantiene que vota más o menos
parecido a lo último
pero hay otra auto grupo de switch que
se llama nuevo personas que entran de
acuerdo al menú de la lección que van
cambiando por lo tanto no sabemos si ese
grupo va a ir a votar ese próximo
domingo y de ese grupo depende de quién
gane en chile
la participación electoral está siempre
en torno el 50 por ciento del padrón el
cual está un poquito inflado porque hay
una serie de casos que todavía no están
claros pero en general en las elecciones
para nosotros normal que hubo en el 50%
lo que pasa es que hay cierto cambio de
electores entre primera y segunda vuelta
y cuando uno suma las dos vueltas te das
el 51 59 por ciento lo cual se acerca a
un régimen más o menos voluntario la
pregunta para el próximo domingo no es
cuántos sino que quienes van a ir porque
esta elección está absolutamente que
llamémosle mencionaba por lo
generacional gabriel boric tiene
solamente 35 años y representa a una
generación que quiere cambio y quiere
esperanza y que está de una forma
representada en la convención
constitucional que está redactando la
nueva constitución y por otra parte
constante notas de derecha de extrema
derecha representa para muchas personas
el pasado de lo que es la época de la
dictadura de pinochet entonces están
esas dos
tensiones a cada persona angela el
último acá lo más importante también es
que los fast y ten bueno 30 años de
estancia en la papeleta sino que están
viviendo por detrás a cada uno lo cambia
con lo cual es un signo de absoluto
cambio